[Musique]
c
mon
les canadiens ont rendu hommage aux
anciens combattants lors de nombreux
cérémonie qui avait lieu aujourd'hui en
ce jour du souvenir ce jour rappelle la
fin de la première guerre mondiale un
conflit pendant lequel près de 61 mille
canadiens ont été tués et 172 milles
autres blessés c'est aussi l'occasion de
se souvenir de tous ceux et celles qui
ont servi en temps de guerre d'ailleurs
il ya près du tiers des vétérans qui
intègre le marché du travail qui disent
éprouver des difficultés à faire cette
transition comment leur assurer un
meilleur accès à l'emploi on va en
parler avec marie-eve plamondon avocate
en droit de l'emploi merci d'être là
madame pendant dont pourquoi c'est
difficile pour les vétérans d'intégrer
le marché du travail c'est quoi les
obstacles et il semble y avoir une
perception chez ces gens là que ils ont
subi nécessairement un poste un syndrome
post traumatique qu'on appelle donc
qu'ils ont un diagnostic qui vont
entraîner des enjeux dans le cadre du
travail
or ceux des pôles code tout c'est tout
c'est à chacune des personnes un cas
d'espèce et donc c'est d'évaluer pour
chacune des personnes si oui ou non il
ya un impact sur la possibilité de faire
les tâches liées au travail
or dans un groupe comme celui là et ses
claques une obligation d'accommodement
même si c'est une perception comme tel
d'handicap pour faut se rappeler que la
charte québécoise des droits des droits
et libertés de la personne dit au fond
qu'à partir du moment que la personne a
un handicap qu'on a une perception que
la personne un handicap on doit comeau
des mêmes dans le cadre de l' embauche
c'est également vrai au niveau de la loi
canadienne au niveau des entreprises
fédérales je pense que le mot clé ici
ses perceptions préjugés bière social
peu importe comment on appelle ça parce
que bon effectivement le fait qu'on peut
surestimer l'impact possède un stress
post traumatique des stéréotypes ou si
on dit que ces gens le sont plus
difficiles à gérer et cetera alors tous
aux cetc faut en fait ce sont des
préjugés que les entreprises on est ce
qu'on peut parler de discrimination mais
oui effectivement à partir du moment que
ces gens là on pense qu'ils ont un suivi
médical qu'ils ont eu des diagnostics
liés aux conditions psychologiques ou à
ce qu'ils ont vécu dans le cas des
années durant lesquelles ils ont servi
bas ce moment l'heure on a une
perception dans ce cas précis suffisant
pour tomber sous les jets de la charte
comme étant la discrimination si on
décide de refuser la personne sur cette
base que sont les droits ce moment
des vétérans qui sont dans cette
situation une obligation pour
l'employeur de d'accommoder cette
personne chose surprenante dans la
documentation liée à cette problématique
là on voit jamais cette analyse le vert
l'accommodement qui pousse les
organisations à accommoder ces gens là
chose certaine la commission des droits
de la personne pourrait davantage de
peut-être faire de la publicité au fait
que ces gens l'ont également doivent
être accommodé mais c'est sûr que la
meilleure solution serait d'ajouter
comme motifs prohibés le fait de
discriminer compte les vétérans de façon
très très clairs et explicites mais même
là il ya quand même une obligation
d'accommodement kiki née du fait qu'une
perception que un handicap ou une
application liée au fait que la personne
servi en temps de guerre est ce qu'on
reconnaît à ce moment là assez bien leur
compétence parce que ces gens là ont une
expérience peut être différente de celle
du milieu du travail mais ont trop
d'autres forces être avec des pieds par
exemple gestion de situations de crise
on s'en doute est ce qu'on reconnaît
suffisamment bien les compétences des
vétérans qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail mais il ya une qu'aucune raison
de ne pas les reconnaître le souvent ces
gens le sont habitués à un certain
niveau de stress à être capable d'avoir
un certain rendement dans une certaines
circonstances qui sont pas faciles donc
aucune raison de ne pas les reconnaître
l'enjeu est davantage de s'assurer que
ces billets là qui tombent sous
facilement sous l'égide de la
discrimination soit évacué du processus
d'embauché et ça c'est vrai pour tous
les motifs prohibés en vertu de la
charte
l'enjeu étant vraiment que les gens ont
cette perception l'homme équipes ont
nécessairement fondés
il faut savoir également que à l'heure
actuelle le pote conflit tout ce dont
les gens qui réintègre n'ont pas
nécessairement vécu donc cette
perception là est peut-être même
complètement faute fausse week et aucune
justification ici là est ce qu'il ya des
programmes est ce qu'on les accompagne
ce que quelque chose qui existent pour
faciliter cette transition lancement
à l'heure actuelle c'est surtout des
organisations de bienfaisance qui font
au sol malheureusement il semble pas y
avoir suffisamment de fonds qui sont
dévouées à ça l'idéal serait que les
gens soient formés de façon à s'assurer
que lui lors de la pré services ils
soient prêts
intégrer la société et réussir dans le
milieu de travail mais encore là il ya
aussi un travail de conscientisation
parce qu'on voit que c'est surtout dans
l'entreprise privée qu'ils ont de la
difficulté à se frayer un chemin suivant
l'organisation c'est ce qui est sans vie
dans les journaux généraux de programme
par exemple pour embaucher
spécifiquement les vétérans aux états
unis à quelques entreprises qu'ils font
ce que c'est au canada
non il n'y a pas d'éléments à ce niveau
là donc ça laisse les gens un peu à eux
mêmes a tenté de faire valoir leurs
compétences donc idéalement ce serait de
bâtir un programme effectivement qui les
aide pour la tr services ya des chiffres
qui montrent madame plamondon qu'il ya
plusieurs vétérans qui perdent du
pouvoir d'achat subissent des baisses de
salaires lorsqu'ils font la transition
du milieu militaire ou de l'armée vers
le marché de l'emploi
comment on explique ça ben vous veut pas
c'est sûr que lorsqu'on est dedans on
sable service saisir certains certains
niveaux hiérarchiques qui permettent de
gravir les échelons peut-être que dans
leur lorsqu'ils tombent dans un milieu
où on est dans l'entreprise privée parce
que les chiffres sortait aussi de
l'entreprise qui verse pas dans
l'entreprise privée ça va être peut-être
d'autres choses qui vont prévaloir au
niveau de l'analyse de combien la
personne mérite en termes salariale
l'analyse salariale et donc c'est dans
ce contexte euler que les gens les gens
perdent mais chose certaine il ya pas
nécessairement de raisons pour ça c'est
peut-être aussi dans la façon dont les
entraîne qu'on doit s'assurer que ces
gens là puissent réussir
suivent un leurre évidemment c'est plus
de 6000 personnes chaque année qui passe
d'un service militaire à au marché de
l'emploi
on est en pénurie de main d'oeuvre il ya
des gains à faire que ce soit pour les
vétérans les entreprises de ce côté là
mais tout à fait effectivement ça fait
partie de toute la politique de
diversité qu'on tente de favoriser et
don juan de pousser chez les entreprises
privées parce qu'on crie pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
il ya tellement de bassin de
main-d'oeuvre car on parle chez les
personnes handicapées si on parle
également les gens qui ont différentes
affectations il ya aucune raison pour
exclure ces gens là évidemment marianne
la banque flamande remercie beaucoup